la Organización de las Naciones Unidas
para la agricultura y la alimentación y
el programa mundial de elementos en
Naciones Unidas alertaron sobre el
hambre en site su ley un barrio urbano
en Puerto Príncipe en Haití 4.7 millones
de personas se encuentran actualmente en
la situación de hambre extrema que
incluya 1.8 millones en fase de
emergencia y por primera vez en el país
19.000 individuos está con un nivel
catalogado como catastrófico sale vamos
al huracastro directora Regional de
programa mundial de alimentos de la ONU
Lola bueno saludarla nuevamente en
nuestro programa directo América de
Francia 24 pero pues lamentable que
siempre sea para malas noticias no Qué
significa este hambre a niveles
catastróficos Lola
Sí buenos días Raúl y realmente estamos
extremadamente preocupados por Haití
como sabes los resultados que tú has
dicho 4.7 millones de personas que casi
la mitad de la población del país en
inseguridad alimentaria como hemos dicho
nosotros el programa mundial de
alimentos y la FAO pero lo que estamos
viendo ahora es realmente inusual
inusual en toda la región tenerla 19.000
personas que realmente están en fase de
catástrofe que significa que muchos de
ellos cuando los hemos hablado no han
comido en las anteriores 24 horas y que
hay más de 20% de las niñas y niños de
site eso ley que están en desnutrición
aguda Esto no es normal en nuestra
región en latinoamérica del Caribe y no
es normal por muchas razones claramente
hablemos de esas razones el Lola no
evidentemente la primera diría yo la
dificultad del ingreso de la ayuda
humanitaria por el problema de seguridad
que hay sobre todo en Puerto Príncipe
debido a estas pandillas también la
falta de precipitaciones que
evidentemente dañan las cosechas el
terremoto que destruyó también muchísima
infraestructura entonces desglosemos un
poco las razones que más le preocupan a
ustedes para poder llevar esta ayuda
humanitaria Sí bueno primero el programa
musical de alimentos está aún en Haití y
continúa trabajando de hecho solo para
decirte que este fin de semana El
domingo por la mañana consiguieron salir
y apoyar a esta población tan vulnerable
en cité de Soleil al menos tres mil
personas recibieron apoyo inmediato Pero
bueno las causas son que llevamos ya más
de cinco semanas casi seis semanas donde
los puertos están cerrados El
combustible no puede salir las personas
no pueden salir de sus casas no hay agua
en en Puerto Prince porque los
generadores amparado el cólera como bien
saben ha comenzado y ya los números
aumentan cada día y lo Aunque todos los
colegas de las Naciones Unidas y de las
ong están intentando hacer su trabajo
también para evitar poniendo centros de
salud etcétera la logística es muy
complicada extremadamente complicada
para llegar a todos estos lugares Porque
necesitamos negociar acceso humanitario
en los barrios dentro de Haití con estas
ganas para que nos dejen pasar para que
podamos entrar atender a las poblaciones
Es realmente catastrófica la situación y
realmente el mundo tiene que prestar
atención Haití Y tenemos todos que
intentar conseguir una solución a este
problema porque no podemos continuar así
la gente va a morir de hambre va a morir
de cólera Vamos a continuar viendo una
deterioración enorme de la de la pobreza
y de la vulnerabilidad en este país sino
actuamos sino continuamos ahí
continuamos haciendo nuestro trabajo
tanto humanitario como de desarrollo no
podemos olvidar el desarrollo en este
país claro Lola y eso le quería
preguntar Qué proyecciones tienen
ustedes actualmente con esta situación
que vive Haití en un futuro cercano no
no sé de aquí a final de año si esto no
se logra resolver además el cólera como
bien lo está comentando
independientemente empeorando toda la
situación Porque evidentemente si no hay
agua pues este problema de correa se va
a acentuar
Sí mira tenemos problemas en Puerto
Príncipe pero también como tú bien
dijistes en las zonas rural en las zonas
Rurales han sido permanentemente
afectadas por sequías o inundaciones o
el terremoto de gran danés el año pasado
en agosto acaban de cumplir apenas un
año en este terremoto y la gente no se
ha conseguido recuperar sin embargo
realmente todos estamos intentando hacer
cosas que sean positivas como compras
locales en la zona donde los
agricultores producen estas compras
locales que vayan a las escuelas pero
también tenemos a millones de niños
ahora sin ir a la escuela Simplemente no
pueden ir a la escuela están cerradas
los colegios Y entonces esa alimentación
escolar o esa alimentación esa educación
de calidad que se le daba porque los
haitianos valoran muchísimo su educación
y mandan a los niños a la escuela niñas
y niños no está sucediendo en este
momento otra otra de las grandes crisis
de esta crisis también dentro de la
crisis pero también en las zonas Rurales
tenemos que ver cómo se pueden recuperar
y realmente continuar produciendo para
que haya producción local y y y
experiencia a nivel local también
programas de protección social que que
se hagan transferencias sociales a las
personas transferencias monetarias como
hacemos el programa mundial de alimentos
con el gobierno y otros para que las
personas puedan atender sus necesidades
básicas pero también comprar localmente
Es decir que no tenemos que solamente
depender de asistencia humanitaria pero
también de programas que en el país
arreglan la situación de una manera más
sostenible pero claramente en este
momento Necesitamos las dos una ayuda
humanitaria intensa para evitar que haya
más mortalidad tanto por salud como por
inseguridad alimentaria y luego también
continuar con los programas más
sostenibles donde el pueblo y las
personas se recuperan a sí mismas y así
mismo Lola podemos ver ante esta
lamentable situación digamos una luz al
final del túnel ustedes prevén que esta
situación la ayuda humanitaria Es
aumente para poder atender a todas a
toda esta población que realmente lo
necesita con
mira en este momento nosotros como
programa mundial de alimentos el año
pasado conseguimos atender con varios
proyectos incluyendo alimentación
escolar protección social compras
locales trabajando con los granjeros
pero también ayuda humanitaria directa a
1.3 millones de personas este año
teníamos en la intención de atender 1.7
millones de personas si la situación
continúa como hasta ahora estas últimas
seis semanas está siendo muy complicado
a atender hemos tenido pillajes de
nuestros almacenes hemos tenido oficinas
quemadas hemos tenido situaciones
dramáticas nuestro personales está tanto
nuestro personal nacional como
internacional que trabaja en Haití está
en una situación muy difícil estamos
intentando ayudarlas a ellos y a ellos
también para que puedan continuar
haciendo esta labor pero es
extremadamente complicado necesitamos
que se abran los espacios que podamos
circular que haya combustible que haya
agua que haya carreteras abiertas
seguimos claro como programa mundial de
alimentos también ofrecemos la logística
humanitaria tenemos aviones y barcazas
en el país que pueden mover a los
colegas de la de salud a los colegas de
seguridad alimentaria pero necesitamos
tener ese espacio para continuar
moviéndonos y en este momento está muy
complicado entonces alcanzar a toda la
gente difícil muy rápidamente 30
segundos cree que esto se puede mejorar
con la llegada al país como lo así lo
pide el gobierno de Los cascos azules de
la ONU Mira ese comentario le vamos a
dejar al Consejo de Seguridad y al
secretario general que tomen las
decisiones oportunas para nosotros como
humanitarios lo que necesitamos es que
ahí sabrá un espacio humanitario que
podamos continuar trabajando
Muchísimas gracias Lola como siempre por
su